these are images you've probably never
seen before it's an atomic bomb
detonating in the heart of the
Australian Outback we're used to hearing
about nuclear testing in the United
States but many Aussies don't realize
that our own country was a testing
ground too and the price Australia paid
for this was steep with devastating
impacts on our people and environment
and to make matters worse Australia
never got to share in any of the
benefits from these tests it was the
British using Australia to test its
bombs they claimed to have cleaned up
the site before handing it back to
Australia with a report saying it was
now safe but in 1984 more than 20 years
after the test program ended Australian
scientists walked the land with Geiger
counters to check for radiation and got
the shock of their lives expecting to
find low levels of contamination they
wore shorts and no protective clothing
but instead their readings fluctuated
wildly as they stumbled over rocks and
soil they realized they were treading on
plutonium so to Earth they even found
chunks of the deadly substance itself
plutonium a man-made element is created
in a nuclear reactor by bombarding
uranium with neutrons the isotope in
question here is plutonium-239 which has
a half-life of over 24 000 years so
remains dangerous practically forever
inhaling just 20 milligrams of plutonium
can cause a fatal illness the scientists
were there to survey the land before it
was to be handed back to the traditional
owners the marilinga jarucha people who
were displaced in their hundreds by the
tests the Australians were shocked and
unprepared for what they found the
British had claimed to have cleaned up
any contamination and the report put
together by UK scientist Noah Pierce
made no mention of these deadly
plutonium fragments it's enough
radioactive material that International
laws would require it to be safeguarded
from Bad actors trying to make a bomb it
also contains secret traces of how the
British bombs were put together but was
just left lying out in the desert
unguarded and undisclosed for decades in
the 50s and 60s the British detonated 12
major atomic bombs and performed
hundreds of related experiments across
Australia leaving many areas permanently
contaminated with deadly radiation it's
a story of harm and negligence that
starts with a few physicists and a
seemingly worthless heavy metal uranium
it's the heaviest of all natural
elements and was known to have more
neutrons than protons in its nucleus
bombarding the nucleus with neutrons at
high speed could cause it to split
undergoing nuclear fission in 1938
researchers in Paris discovered that the
uranium atom flings out extra neutrons
when split no one initially thought
those new neutrons could be harnessed or
controlled for anything but soon
theories of a chain reaction made a bomb
possible Niels Bohr and John Wheeler
published a memo on the fission process
just three days before war broke out
putting everyone on the same starting
line
uranium t35 could easily sustain a chain
reaction where the neutrons flung out by
one nuclei splitting would go off and
cause other nuclei to split each time
releasing a great deal of energy a
material reaches critical mass when more
neutrons can go off and split other
nuclei than are lost in the reaction
Auto fresh and Rudolf purells working in
England found that just a few pounds of
uranium-235 were needed to reach
critical mass the British secretly
worked on this idea under a deliberately
boring sounding name the tube Alloys the
British were well in front of the
Americans at this stage and in 1941
British research was given to the US
where it fueled the Manhattan Project
that culminated in the dropping of bombs
on Hiroshima and Nagasaki in 1945.
after this the US didn't need the
British anymore and after a couple of
high-profile Atomic spies were
discovered they didn't trust the UK to
keep secrets
UK physicists were shutout and the
atomic energy Act was introduced by the
US in 1946 that banned collaboration on
nuclear weapons development it took the
British by surprise and this betrayal
was why Britain turned to developing
their own bombs and ended up coming to
Australia to test them Australia had
their own reasons for allowing them to
one Australia wanted to maximize the
value of its extensive uranium resources
two they thought that helping the
British might protect them in case of a
nuclear war and three they wanted to
learn from the British in case they ever
decided to make their own nuclear
weapons or energy but the British
provided no nuclear secrets to Australia
and Australia was reluctant to ask
Australia was an ideal location for the
British tests there were vast areas of
land we had a prime minister who said
yes without asking too many questions
and well it wasn't written and any harm
would be out of sight and out of mind
for them
the British arrived in Australia in 1952
and tested their first atomic bomb at
the Montebello Islands they were Keen to
test the effects of detonating a weapon
in the hold of a ship and analyzing the
specifics of a phenomenon called base
surge which involved a large upward
movement of radioactive water the weapon
was 25 kilotons which is 10 kilotons
more than the bomb that was dropped on
Hiroshima so it was a very powerful
weapon it was one of the most powerful
not the but one of the most powerful
bombs detonated in Australia it did
spread fall out over a wide area that is
still actually being investigated
scientifically I do know from my own
research that the Fallout went as far as
Brisbane so it was tracked across the
continent for the next tests the British
moved to EMU field in the Australian
desert their operation totem detonated
more bombs this time testing the impact
of differing proportions of plutonium
they left a kilometer-wide patch where
the Earth was heated to such high
temperatures that it became glass totem
one which was designated on the 15th of
October of 1953 created a very
mysterious phenomenon that later became
known as the black mist
we still don't fully understand what the
black mist was we do know that it
traveled about 170 kilometers to the
northeast of the Emu field site where it
rolled over largely indigenous
populations around the settlements of
volatino and granite Downs that kind of
area
we know that it was a very strange
phenomenon a a greasy black cloud that
had a strange smell some people said it
smelled like kerosene other people said
it smelled like a dead kangaroo and it
stuck to everything
and very soon after the black mist
rolled over those communities people
started to get very ill and some people
died some people had chronic illnesses
some people reported eye problems and
indeed blindness next Britain's Focus
shifted to testing a hydrogen bomb
before an international treaty to limit
nuclear weapons testing took effect
since hydrogen bombs are even more
powerful than Atomic ones Australia did
actually put its foot down and said no
to testing them so instead the British
just tested a device they could operate
as a fission trigger for one and this
Remains the biggest Atomic device ever
to explode in Australia it was tested
back at the Montebello Islands in June
1956. its Cloud Rose 14 000 meters high
so different from what authorities had
predicted that many people thought
something had gone terribly wrong
back in the desert in
1956-57 this time at a more permanent
base at maralinga seven more atomic
bombs were detonated as part of
operations Buffalo and antler these were
detonated in a few ways from steel
Towers dropped from aircraft or from
tethered balloons 300 meters high there
was also Buffalo 2 detonated at ground
level that created a 21 meter deep bomb
crater damage from these tests spread
over a large part of the continent but
the worst was still to come the most
dangerous scientific experiments in
Australia's history were the Vixen B
series of so-called minor trials
conducted between 1959 and 1963. the
minor trials and that name is rather
ironic and it's kind of deliberate as
well it was intended to be misleading
they were extremely dangerous and
extremely damn Imaging the Vixen B trial
involved using conventional explosives
to detonate a lump of plutonium this is
a test to see what would happen if an
aircraft carrying
uh an atomic weapon crashed or caught
fire or you know there was some accident
or even terrorism there were 12 Vixen B
tests altogether and in one of those we
know for sure a chain reaction did
eventuate so that is it was a small
atomic weapon
the rest of them were more like what
would be known today as dirty bombs
suitcase bombs they were they just
spread the radioactive material uh in a
in a plume shape across the landscape
essentially vixenbee left
more than 20 kilograms of plutonium-239
at the site without any safeguards and
that had implications later for
international agreements that Australia
was party to but also just for anyone
who happened to enter that territory
they were at risk of exposure to highly
dangerous material
secrecy and cover-ups meant the British
nuclear tests in Australia remained
mysterious for decades until a royal
commission presented the findings of its
investigations in 1985 Australia really
had no idea what had gone on the tests
massively disrupted and harmed the
Aboriginal people who didn't have the
federal vote and were not counted in the
census until
1967. in Maryland people spotted living
on the land were directed to a station
at yalatar still small groups did walk
across the grounds after the tests began
the native Patrol Officer William
McDougall and his offside of Bob
McCauley they had the task of keeping
Aboriginal people away from the site and
that was an impossible task given the
size of the territory and the
um the the routes between water holes
and people visiting family you know it
was a it was a busy place and people
were traversing the territory all the
time one particularly famous example of
that happening during the tests was the
mill putty family they walked onto the
marolingo range in 1957 several months
after a test had been held at a site
called Marco the only bomb test at
maralinga that involved detonating a
device on the ground and so it created a
crater a very deep and wide crater the
more putty family camped by the side of
that crater they weren't found until a
patrol the next morning
and they were hastily taken away it was
the father mother and children and some
dogs
and they were
rather brutally showered and had Geico
counters run over them on the orders of
Minister for Supply Howard Bill their
dogs were shot in front of them
Eddie milpadi the wife was pregnant at
the time and she lost her baby soon
after there were plenty of other
instances where people were treated just
as harshly placed onto trucks taken away
to places on The Great Australian bite
to missions and places like that were
you know losing contact with their their
land
and so the mill putty story is an
important one on a human level to
understand what happened to real people
who were displaced and mistreated by the
British Childs the British did not
accurately describe what they were
leaving behind low-rank military
personnel put together the data in the
PS report and their measurements lacked
an understanding of how radiation could
be dispersed that was strange since
understanding the dispersal of radiation
and its consequences on the environment
was an important part of what the
British were hoping to gain from the
tests in the first place the British
cleanup was inadequate they churned up
the topsoil using a tractor instead of
removing all the plutonium the Royal
commission said that maralinga is
probably the only place in the western
world where plutonium is dispersed
without precise knowledge of how much is
above and below ground another cleanup
of miralinga was organized by Australia
in the mid-1990s and involved sealing
material into concrete pits there's
still quite a bit of controversy about
whether or not that was adequate however
I'm satisfied that the site is much
safer than it was before the the cleanup
so there is still limits on visiting
there there are time limits on how long
you can spend on the site and no one can
stay there indefinitely in the forward
range part of the of the Maryland range
the half-life of plutonium-239 is 24 400
years so it you don't get rid of it in
on human time scales anyway so yes it's
uh no one will ever be able to inhabit
those places the state that emu field
and Montebello were left in by the
British was not much better and today
there are still signs warning tourists
not to stay longer than an hour
Australia fronted many of the running
costs and gave political backing and
military personnel but was never in
charge or privy to the information
gained the media was muzzled by strict
government censorship and the public was
kept in the dark about the potential
dangers of radioactive fallout military
personnel involved in the tests were
exposed to dangerous levels of radiation
and many have suffered severe Health
consequences indigenous communities
living near where the test took place
were not consulted or informed of the
dangers they faced and many were forced
to abandon their ancestral lands and
relocate to other areas I think we all
as Australians have an obligation to
make sure that this never happens again
I think it's a very very dark era in
Australian history and we need to guard
against government secrecy and um
under the table agreements between
Australia and the so-called great powers
despite the passage of time the truth
remains unknown the legacy of the
nuclear tests in Australia is a chilling
reminder of the dangerous power physics
has given us and the lasting
consequences of our actions
this video covered a serious topic and
if you're looking for something a little
more light-hearted to watch next I'd
like to tell you about a new video
series that I'm involved with earlier
this year I traveled across New Zealand
with some friends as part of a
competitive game-based reality show
called jet lag it was a fun and
stressful way to see the country and it
was a chance for me to show off a
different side of my personality since
we filmed it in a relaxed Vlog style
format jet lag is a nebula first show
meaning that it is always one episode
ahead on nebula compared to YouTube but
what is nebula well it is a
creator-owned streaming service that I
just joined and it allows YouTubers to
create cool and ambitious content that
they wouldn't be able to make otherwise
buying a nebula subscription is a way to
support me directly and a bunch of other
creators they have Originals such as up
and atoms is math invented or discovered
and they have a new feature called
nebula classes teaching a range of
topics related to content creation if
you sign up using my link below you
support me directly and get access to
nebula and nebula classes for around
2.50 per month or 30 USD per year using
my link gives 40 off the annual plan if
you join nebula you can also listen to
The Exclusive podcast The Layover which
I'm on with the guys from jet lag
talking all about the decisions that we
made on the show and what happened
behind the scenes thanks for watching
this video and thanks to my patreon
supporters including today's patreon cat
of the day Jan
[Music]
thank you